hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2009 18-grand KHS classic
tournament here we have practically an
identical situation like if the
candidates Faviana Khurana is half a
point in the lead in front of everyone
else he has the black pieces in in the
last round and he plays the petro
defense in the last round so this is
this is definitely definitely something
to remember and it's a quite an
excellent game Nikita with you go came
very well prepared but to his own
fortune
so did Fabiano so let's just let's just
check out this game and I don't have any
any photos of this round but I will
probably show one more game as - is his
up two pawns in her game against
Arcadian idak so perhaps she will she
will maybe win this game and I will have
finally a win by easy fun to show you
guys so let's see this game Vaclav goes
efore and yeah I forgot to mention but
if you've seen my previous video you
know that V Google is a trailing half a
point behind Fabiano same as Magnus
Carlsen so if V Cube wins his game he
has like huge chances of winning the
Greenwich a spicy because Carlson is
facing Anand with the black pieces and
he has to he basically has the beat
Island with the black pieces to win it
so e4 and we have e v Knight to f3
Knight to f6 the Petrov defense by
Fabiano this is like the standard now he
plays against t4 he will go for the
better of every game it was only against
Sergei Sergei carking that he lost one
game but you know other than that he
really creates nice positions and gains
a lot of good results using the Petrov
and I do accept I had to expect a lot of
people to you know start using the
petrov again and you know she'll become
quite fashionable d4 who we have the
Steiners attack
knife characters only 4d captures on e5
so the same the same variation that was
played in the last round of the
candidates between Greece Turkey and
Fabiano Caruana here we have d5 Knight
d2 fatigue of goes for the same the same
variation
played against Fabiano and in the game
against Greece sugar Fabiano played
Knight captures on d2 and this is what
Nikita b2 was prepared for but at his
unfortune fabiano actually checked this
position after the candidates he went
out celebrating and of course the next
day he had a couple of hours to spare
and then he checked this position out on
the computer and he he found an
improvement here he played Queen to d7
and Queen 37 is is a really weird move
why do you play Queen to d7 I mean why
can't simply capture after he captures
back then Queens can come off the board
and basically it seems like we just lost
the tempo but to win the tournament
Nikita has to go for a win as well so
definitely we're not gonna play Knight
captures on e4 another thing is Queen d7
is it actually threatening anything
what's Queen d7 doing it's basically
looking like a very weird move but it is
the top engine recommendation and all
the way to this point although affair or
I mean this is move five now it's a
video course turn to make move six but
after this point the moves were pretty
much placed out and here it took with
you of over ten minutes to decide on his
next move here of course he didn't
capture as you know that just wouldn't
make sense if you want to create
anything with white as you play Bishop
to d3 so developing a bishop and of
course nice to see five here by Fabiano
leaving the options for this night to go
either to e6 he would of course enjoy
capturing the light square bishop so
Bishop to e2 and now g6 preparing to
develop the dark square Bishop on g7
nice to be three and now nice to e6
avoiding a trade of knights Bishop to e3
now comes c5 with some future d4 ideas
and here Knight to g5 also Queen to d2
was something Fabiana was also expecting
as he did prepared this variation with
Queen to d7 so he does know some of the
ins and outs of the position but he
wouldn't allow better to h6 or anything
like that he had h6 prepared and here
after c3 probably Bishop to b6 and after
castles Bishop to be
and he said that he was very happy if if
he got this position with black he
doesn't really see a good move for white
here in this position
so after c5 Knight to g5 again we have
be sexier and here he he did think about
the early d4 but the early d4 you you
give this Knight a square on e4 now of
course you can't capture the bishop
because Knight f6 check you lose the
Queen
so after Bishop to e7 now Bishop to h6
again getting a lot of space here and
after Knight to c6 White Castle and then
Knight captures on e5 and f4 so he could
grab some material but it would be a
very dangerous position for him Knight
moves now f5g captures rook captures and
you know this bishop is still on c8 the
queen is now ridiculous on d7 the
Knights are blocking the Queen the Queen
is blocking the bishop the King side is
busted open the rock is on on f5 i f7
the bishop can come to h5 could be very
dangerous for black so he doesn't want
to go for the early d4 so instead b6 now
so keeping the C pawn safe and you know
waiting to see what the Viterbo will do
we have Knight captures on his six F
captures and e6 and now a4 and I did
catch a glimpse of an interview with
cousin Anand and of course and said that
a four might not have been the greatest
of moves because as he puts it the
position is screaming for d4 so
naturally a c3 might have been a better
choice but okay a for Bishop to b7 and
now white castles here again even Fabi
agrees that maybe c3 was a better idea
here there's no reason for for whites to
allow d4
but perhaps the vicar also wants some
some inequality in the position to maybe
create some winning chances so okay he
castles and now Knight to c6 f4 and
Bishop to h6 now of course you can you
can't really go for f5 or anything here
because you're better poetry will be
hanging so a five and again
a very provocative move here if you if
you go for castles which is something
you definitely want to do you allow this
a six move and this pretty much again
forces your Bishop back to c8 again your
position looks it doesn't look very
appealing the Rope can come into the
game the bishop is again a lot can see
it at the Queen is once again looking
pretty ridiculous and d7 blocking the
bishop so instead Knight to e7
now if no if white pushes a6 there's
really no no threat to it Bishop to g4
Bishop to g4 was played what's the idea
with the idea of the Queen coming to f3
or d3 and later riemann over into queen
over to h3 so the queen and the bishop
can create some threats against this e
six pawn but focuses that the the this
did come kind of as a surprise to him
and he didn't mind so immediately d4
Bishop to c1 and now he castles here
comes Queen to d3 this was all prepared
for by v2 between two h3 is now coming
and the bishop will create a nice threat
against d6 pawn and here
Bishop to d5 Bobby did consider playing
nice to a5 but he no moral abyss of to
f3 at the trade off of the bishops here
as he does prefer his b7 Bishop a lot
more than this weird Bishop on g4 so
Queen to d3 now Bishop to d5 and now
Queen to h3 so now the bishop is only
five already he's protecting these six
points so Queen Queen h3 is not coming
with such a terrible threat with the
attack on the east exponent also on the
bishop on h6 so Bishop to g7 getting the
best part of the way
Knight to d2 and now Knight to f5 c4
which did come quite as quite of an
unpleasant surprise to Fabi he was
expecting c3 and here he kinda did
consider not capturing one person but
you know his instincts told him that he
wants to preserve his past D pawn but he
just he just couldn't figure out how how
to actually do it so he played D captors
on seat
three captures on c3 and rook a to d8 so
a very nice control on the D file when
this bishop removes the Queen can
infiltrate on d3 if the exchange of
Queens happened and the rook is coming
to d3 the other rook is doubling up on
the D file a very pleasant position for
black we have pawn captures pawn
captures and now rook to e1 b5 Knight to
e4 and now Queen to e7 Queen to e7 to
guard against this Knight to f6 idea but
also Bishop captures Bishop captures
night was definitely a possibility and
it is the engine stop recommendation but
it's very hard as beetle echo says for a
human to decide to do something like
this
I give up you're strong Bishop I mean it
is a strong night but you don't want to
give up the bishop pair too early so
Queen to e7 and now Knight to g5 also
instead of this Knight to g5 focuses
that this was maybe maybe White's best
attempt Bishop to a3 allowing before now
CSC capture C captures and after Bishop
to b2 now Bishop would capture Knight
rook characters and now Queen to see if
I would check King to h1 now Queen to c2
attacking the bishop on B to rook after
some before this was all this is all
forced the defending the bishop rub the
d3 attacking the Queen now Bishop to f3
defending rook F to d8 a threatening
rook to d1 now rook to g1 not allowing
rook to do you want to come with temple
and now Bishop to f8 and this is amazing
this Bishop to f8 this is like a seven
more variation it's all forced but now
we have to find the bishop f8 to
actually see that this is excellent for
blacks without Bishop f8 there's really
no way to continue this position for
black to like have an advantage and it's
very I mean it was very funny when fact
probably was explaining the position
after the game he actually got to this
position and he said yeah maybe maybe I
didn't even see anything here you know
maybe it's not that good for black but
then he remembers yeah there was Bishop
f8 and in reality Bishop to f8 is the
only move engine gives the game
advantage for black because after Bishop
to f8 you're attacking this rook also
you're threatening Bishop to c5 and he
even saw that after rook to b7
threatening checkmate on h7 he you can
play h5 and again Bishop is coming to c5
the rook will have to move from g1 it
will be an excellent position for black
so this is a something just something
Fabi saw if Bishop to e3 was played but
it wasn't so instead Knight to g5 by the
cube of h6 attacking the knight Knight
moves back and now Bishop the c6 and
it's a very hard position for white the
rook is coming to d3 there's very little
you can do about that
Bishop captures on f5 we have pawn
captures and now Bishop to e3 so the
rook readily comes to d3 rook 8 2 c1
defending the pawn and now rook to e8
preparing to infiltrate via da file
Queen to h4 offering a trade of Queens
Fabia was very happy when he saw this
Queen captures Knight captures and now
c4 pushing those ponds and the
solidifying the the position of that
rook and III King to f2 now Bishop to f8
Knight to f3 Bishop to d5 and Knights
the d4 here Bishop to c5 was played and
here far we expected nice to see to
simply getting the knight out of the way
the bishop would be defended by the
night end by the rook so no harm there
but here another problem for V to go
other than having an inferior position
it's time he was in serious time trouble
so this is moved 35 he's about to make
his move 36 and he was down to some 2
minutes I believe so he had to make
formal moves in those 2 minutes
so instead retreating with the night
it's like even chip says the hardest
move to find is with Knight back so here
he played Knight captures an f5 with the
idea of if EK % i5 of course he grabs
the Bishop on c5 but [ __ ] played
Bishop to a3 now your knight on f5 is
still attacked there is a threat against
the rook and c1 so Knight captures an 8
six grabbing another pawn with check
first King to g7 and now f5 f5 they're
really the rule wasn't a better move
here and this is move this move 37 so
waiting to make move 38 whatever you
play here you're still gonna you're
still gonna lose a piece so f5 preparing
f6 to create a nice passed pawn also the
bishop is now guarding the night here
but here Fabi simply played Bishop
captures on c1 he did consider he did
consider some other things he thought
that maybe ro captures and if on e3 was
like winning instantly but after King
captures Bishop captures and see one
rook captures and King characters on h6
King before and you know it could be it
could be dangerous he didn't want to
risk it he is up a piece but he only has
three pawns and he white king is very
active in the center so no reason to do
this
so after f5 Bishop captures on c1 Bishop
captures now rook captures on c3 f6 with
check and here Fabi play King to g6 and
he got off off off of the table and he
you know went went on to take a walk as
this is more 40 so the time control has
been reached and it was in this position
that Nikita be tube of while Fabiano
corona was absent from the table decided
to resign the game so here he stopped
the clock
Fabiano came back to the table he shook
his hand and he resigned the game so
basically Fabiano won this game and also
for the Encore wanna won the Greinke
chess classic 2018 it doesn't matter if
you don't still know the other results
but as Fabiana was half a point in the
lead before he even came to the last
round with a win in the last round he is
in clear first place no one can catch up
to him but yeah I will show a couple of
other games like I said how if an arc a
denied eg and still being played with a
promising position for even soul perhaps
perhaps that one and maybe even the
cousin Anand won also a very nice game
but yeah a spectacular showing by
Caruana
not just this game but the entire
tournament and the entire previous
tournament so again he you know
first place with a win with the black
pieces in endo in the last round and
with none other than the Petrov defense
that's that's that's amazingly cool so
yeah it seems like 2018 is the year of
Fabiano Caruana will it be a dear
Fabiano
Khurana all the way to November we'll
just have to wait and see 2017 seems to
have been the year of Levin Oregon in
2016 maybe the year of Wesley so but you
know every player seems to have his ear
Oh we'll see how it turns out so
basically that's it I do hope you
enjoyed the game and the entire coverage
of this tournament I will probably show
one more game tomorrow morning and then
continue with some classics you know we
should definitely take a rest from
modern chess and revisit the the actual
good chess the hand that was played long
ago so yeah I would like to thank a
Brandon booth for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you